let me ask you this are you worried
about like I'm not saying you you have
stuff like that in your phone of
yourself but uh you're obviously really
famous
so would you ever like freak like do you
ever worry if like dang I don't know if
you've ever sent wild photos to people
in life but like if you have like damn
them shits in my leak one day or do you
not give a [ __ ]
you know that's a good question I never
thought about that
I don't know how I feel yeah I mean you
know I always say like uh
go ahead leak them whatever you know you
know one of my homegirls always told me
because this is what she did like she
always makes sure like
the photo is Tip Top so it forever got
out it's just like oh well yeah it's
like it's almost like a business card
a business card well I'm not I mean I'm
not saying I mean like you know
okay you know what I mean okay that
sounded terrible I do that sounded bad
she's like what are you trying to say I
don't have a [ __ ] only fan Jesus by
the way
you should do it only fans with
financial literacy advice on it I always
think
no ddg ddg's only fans
I haven't I didn't subscribe he told me
this but he's like uh he's you subscribe
and it gives you like YouTube tips and
stuff you know oh wow and there's like
Cooks who have recipes on there it's not
just for the smut you know I mean DJ
Khaled and Fat Joe had a joint only fans
account for a little bit really yeah I
didn't know that yeah they were just
doing like it was like a
like a buddy cop movie but just on only
fans between calendar and Fat Joe so you
know